الذي يجف وزوال الفرح
بالنسبه لهؤلاء الطلاب مرتبطا بغياب ماده
المازوت او الديزل عن المدفاه
نادرا ما ينعم الصفه بالدفء لذلك يتحصن
تلاميذ بملابس سميكه لمواجهه درجات
الحراره المتدنيه في عكار الجبلي شماليه
لبنان
[موسيقى]
ما فينا نركز
تقول اداره المدرسه انها تعتمد برنامجا
لتشغيل المدافع فاسعار المحروقات ارتفعت
في ظل محدوديه الاقساط بسبب انخفاض قيمه
ليره
تحول جزء من المصاريف اللي هي المفروض
تكون مصاريف لتطوير المدرسه لتحسين
المدرسي للامور اليوميه الضروريه بالمدرسه
عم تحولها الى التدفيه
اللبنانيين مع انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
ورفع الدعم الحكومي كليا على المحروقات
وبات التكلفه تامين المازوت خلال الشتاء
باهظه على العائلات
لجا كثيرون الى الحطب الذي يباع ايضا
بالدولار او بالليره وفق سعر الصرف في
السوق الموازيه بلال واحد من من تخلو عن
مدفاه المحروقات سعيا منه الى خفض النفقات
في الزمن الصعب كما يصفوه
لكن نحن بشكل
كما يقولون بسبب تراجع القدرات الشرائيه
للبنين
من سنتين ثلاثه اربعه قبل
ما كان فيها طلب مثل هذه السنه هذه السنه
فيها طلب كثير مثلا
خفيف ومقبول كتير
مع ارتفاع اسعار الحديد عالميا بين برد
الشتاء القارس وتداعيات الانهيار
الاقتصاديه اقلام اللبنانيون مجبرينا مع
واقع صعب لتامين بعض الديسك واقع قد
يتفاقم طالما ضل تدهور المني على على مع
غياب اي معالجات رسميه جونيتون يونس
الجزيره شماليه لبنان